yeah hello and welcome to this video a
little bit different than usual
this is a short book review and I had
planned a more extensive book review
video anyway before Christmas I know
that people like that a lot that I
recommend some books before Christmas
time you might yeah buy gifts for
yourself here to study during the the
holidays or you might get yeah loved
ones to buy a good chest book for you
I'm going to do this video and I'm I
planned it for early December this time
last year I was really a bit late with
that anyway I have this planned and I
have already a stack of books that I
will show you and one of those books I'm
actually now going to do the review form
a little bit earlier than intended
roughly two or three weeks before I
wanted to do it because there is a good
reason to do it right now we'll get to
that in a minute or you might see it
there on the on the text here in the
video because you can actually save a
bit of money if you want so what is that
book all about what book am I talking
about it's um I think one of the best
books that was released this year and it
is this one small steps to giant
improvement I have the actual book
really by Sam Shanklin to the current
the reigning US Champion yeah Shanklin
is probably the Player of the Year I
mean the only possibility that he
shouldn't be called Player of the Year
would be that karana wins the World
Championships maybe but other than that
Shanklin does the player of the year
played a fantastic year twenty twenty
eighteen winning the US Championships
ahead of everybody like Khurana
so Nakamura he won this tournament and
yeah also got his rating to 2700 level
now he's one of the top 30 players in
the world I think roughly I could pull
up the world rankings but something like
that it certainly is he also won two or
other big tournaments so really great
year and he has released his first book
this small steps to giant improvement
and what is it all about you probably
cannot read this it's just too small
right if I put this here you say master
pong playing chess so it is all about
pong play and this is also where the
small steps come in pawns go small steps
but they are really key to giant
improvement I'm starting now here with
the page on the quality chess website
where the original book is is linked it
has they have a PDF excerpt and also
some information the book God really
fantastic reviews here by Matthew Sadler
casts and Hanson and John Hartman and
now you can add my review to that I
think it's really an excellent book so
why am I putting this on now and not for
the holiday sales season in two or three
weeks the reason is that if you buy that
as a book like a print book not sure
that you can read that at thirty two
point ninety nine euros which makes it
what is that what he dollars roughly hmm
give or take roughly forty don't ya be
too harsh on me if I'm not precise there
but roughly 40 US dollars and currently
there is a sale for that book as a
chasuble version it was just released
like two days ago
I think November 15 three days ago
and I noticed that that there was a sale
going on and the intro offer is actually
yeah twenty four point ninety nine US
dollars which makes it really a lot
cheaper than the print book and it works
well in jessabelle I have checked it and
it's a really really nice way to study
in the book and you save a lot of money
compared to the print version also I
failed it is sometimes quite handy to
have it online so you don't have to
carry the book with you I have used the
book extensively the print version
really in my chess lessons and it's not
a bad thing to have it
online like chasuble where you can
basically pull up your mobile and look
at positions if you want yeah that's a
good a good thing to be possible so this
is now on sale and I wish to talk a
little bit more about the book itself so
it is about porn play and I'm switching
to another view here ingestible I hope
that I'm Emma locked in there I think it
probably locked me out yeah I have to
log in again so that I actually can go
into the the chapter view um so let's
say we can go into the chapter see em
and you probably cannot read that right
yeah it's so small but otherwise I
couldn't get it on the screen so it is
um it is structured in I think it's four
or five big chapters problem here are
four parts and then we have have
chapters and they have names like
protecting your children avoiding
potholes and so on it's got some funny
names and I think in the book is written
very well like language wise I like the
very clear and and straightforward
language it's very much if you have seen
Shanklin giving an interview I was
talking about his games it's always very
clear and very straightforward with his
language always very honest sometimes
brutally honest and it kind of it is it
has this the book has the same tone it's
very objective it feels very very well
thought-out and very understandable
I failed not very cryptic how you view
you oftentimes sometimes you have books
that have a somewhat complicated
language and somehow I feel it is very
very straightforward if that is the
right word so how does that work what is
the concept of the book it's about palm
play and often the decision is simply
should I move this pawn or not is that a
good decision to change the pawn
structure and what I liked a lot as he
has used in many examples that are not
so well known even to people yeah
honestly like me who knows not
everything but lots of classic examples
because what
does he often takes his own games or
takes very recent games we found really
great examples there are also some old
ones them but mostly they are new and I
think I just want to show you an example
to some what what is all about yeah so
I'm going into one of those chapters and
then pull up simply one of the position
that he examines and this is one of the
exercise positions so let's go jump
right in
I want to make this a little bit bigger
so that you can actually see it you
should see the whole board yeah I said
okay yeah I think it's okay
I didn't rehearse the video very
extensively I just wanted to get the
information across so this is one of
them exercise positions in the book and
it's a game between Shanklin and
Marquess Amon where it is wide to move
and Shanklin I can probably read that
out
he says white would love to advance a
c-pawn and trade on b5 opening the
queenside and fixing black with the long
term weakness that's a very
understandable idea yeah white wants to
play I cannot paint in this in this
board view him like he wants to go see
for take and settled black with the
weakness on b5 if he advances c3 c4 here
black will play before keeping the
Queen's are closed and securing the c5
outpost for his Knights should white
play c4 or not this is the exercise
position and he has before coming to
this position also put out some examples
and of how those kind of decisions can
be examined and can be let's say yeah
you can how you can consider pros and
cons this is the exercise already in the
position to look at so what about this
position I'm going in chasuble here we
can go to the analysis you and how that
was the wrong one wait wait why don't do
it I just found it so Tia analysis body
I just just clicked on the wrong thing
can you see that I think it's it's not
really big but I don't know how to zoom
it in a way that you can still see at
him in in my software to record so let's
talk about this a little bit so we would
think about see for him and he says yeah
black guy was before and I don't think I
can paint here right now um that black
wants to get there 692 c5 to the c5
square and yeah this is indeed possibly
a problem yeah if the knight comes to c5
and this is something where you should
try to solve it if you want you can
really make an exercise all of that and
think about this now is this a good
position for white black wants to play
ninety seven fifty five and this is an
interesting question is that a favorable
change of pawn structure or not
ultimately um you might come up with the
right solution and I'm going to going to
show it this is indeed a good decision
for white because before is not a real
issue the problem with it is that white
can actually prevent the idea 97 to c5
and this brings us to the solution of
this we can also set here on that page
yeah I think if we go onto next page
shows the solution so if you do that in
chess ago you first see the exercise
then you can jump to the solution page
this is oftentimes an issue in books
that you get spoilered yeah all the time
when you can look at like two positions
on a page or four and then you look at
you just want to see one solution then
you see all of them on one page that
sometimes the problem with the print
book so see forum play it before and now
the key move is night sorry it screen to
a fourth this is a key idea because we
look at the d7 square and by preventing
97 this black maneuver is not even
happening that is the thing we are with
B form like
this idea to play the knight to c5 but
it does never arrive there under good
conditions one Kia point is that we are
simply controlling the square and
oftentimes preventing the idea right
away is the best one in this particular
case black has different choices he can
go rook c7 like s emitted in the game
but the more interesting line is
probably the move a five-night b3 and
now we see it an additional idea we
might just win the a pawn you can say
okay what is eco a5 does that make any
sense the problem is if we go back again
here one point for white is also queen
a5 to prevent a5 altogether and isolate
the before pawn from the black camp I
think this is a fantastically
instructive example that an idea
relating to a pawn structure might be
relevant but sometimes it is just not
happening because you can prevent it so
here white goes for a favorable pawn
structure transformation without
allowing the key idea 9725
he explains that really nicely here in
the text I just wanted to show a typical
example of what this book is about it
has those kind of instructive positions
and games that show how pawn structure
decision can be made and how you can
possibly improve your decision-making in
those situations and I think it's a it's
a really great book it has some how many
pages does it have like 300 something
pages so many many good examples and
there's a good variety in there and
there are all kinds of position types
sometimes you have to I think sometimes
issue that if you look at book or some
positional chess they all have those
ultra closed positions like out of the
Kings Indian or whatever we have there's
maneuvering going on and this book is
very versatile in that regard he also
has pawn structure decisions for example
in the Sicilian or this is also
reasonably close position but that was
clearly a rule
so there's a wide variety of position
times if you want to get a good book on
strategy on pawn structure and pawn play
this is a great one to get it's great in
as a paper book as a print book but
untestable it works very well and is on
sale as mentioned it's um it's a good
opportunity I think still for what is
that five days yeah five days and a
couple of hours on sale note that on
chasuble if you don't like it you have a
return you have a refund policy it's a
it's a great opportunity I think to get
this a good content for a really really
good price yeah thanks a lot for
watching this short video I think this
is my favorite book from this year I
think I mean maybe I have to say that I
mean I have a book out myself and also
like that one but it from the books that
I've gotten from other authors this is
fantastic there recently was the Book of
the Year award when this finished second
yeah and to be honest I liked it more
than the winner which is also
interesting book but yeah it has a very
has received very favorable reviews and
this is yet another one that I can add
to that yeah go get the book if you want
something cool on strategy thanks a lot
for watching